we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day I got a call now that
the NFL season is starting back up about
the protests by NFL players who kneel
during the national anthem here is what
that voicemail said hello David Pakman
big fan of yourself I just thought of
something rather fascinating
so all these NFL players that are
kneeling I would like to know what your
thoughts would be if they were kneeling
to end the military-industrial complex
if let's say the NFL players decided to
not only kneel for police brutality
being minimalized
our yeah so but the important thing here
is I don't care why they're kneeling
right that's the thing whether I agree
with why they are kneeling or not it
doesn't change the underlying reality of
what's going on which is that it is a
form of speech and I support that it's
not violent it is calling attention to
an issue that is important to them it
doesn't matter what I think about it now
I think it would be great to have more
proactive protests of the
military-industrial complex but my
opinion doesn't matter my opinion
doesn't matter and it is a distraction
not in the sense that it's not a
relevant issue but it's a distraction to
focus on the reason they are protesting
they have the right to do it they should
not be punished a period we have
hopefully a great bonus show coming up
for you today we will hear about Pats
vacation I will tell you about the
continued tech troubles going on here in
Paris France and much more don't miss
today's bonus show sign up at wwlp.com
coupon code available if you want it
vote soon 18 I will speak to you then